Welcome to the lesson on feature scaling.
Feature scaling is an important step in pre-processing your features for
some types of machine learning algorithms.
We'll talk a little bit later in this lesson exactly where you need to use it.
Let me start out by giving you some intuition for what it accomplishes and
what can go wrong when you don't do feature scaling.
So let's suppose I have a buddy Chris and
Chris wants to know what size T-shirt he should wear.
For some reason he doesn't know his t-shirt size but he does know two good
friends Cameron and Sarah and they each know their t-shirt sizes.
Chris can than get some data from Cameron and
Sarah about say how tall they are and how much they weigh.
And based on this information Chris can tell what size t-shirt he should be
wearing based on whether he is closer in size to Cameron or to Sarah.
So here are some numbers to make this more concrete.
Chris is tall and very skinny.
He weighs 140 pounds and he's 6.1 feet tall.
Cameron is also fairly tall, but not quite so skinny.
He clocks in at a 175 pounds and 5.9 feet.
And Sarah's pretty petite.
She's 115 pounds and 5.2 feet tall.
Cameron of course wears a size large T-shirt, Sarah wears a size small, and
we'll assume for
the sake of argument that there's no such thing as a medium in this example.
So my first question for you is just your intuition.
Should Chris wear a large like Cameron or
a small like Sarah, based on his height and his weight?